Benjamin on s'engueule souvent on se
brouille dans les micro-ondes
dans l'émission t'es pas très bon et ça
c'est vrai mais il y a un vrai ami et
comme un frère et à chaque fois qu'on a
besoin l'un de l'autre tu es là pour moi
je suis là pour toi on est vraiment amis
on bosse ensemble du fond du cœur dans
un main je suis content de t'avoir connu
et je t'aime mon frère
c'est bon
c'est très bon
ça me dégoûte franchement je sais pas si
vous quittez moi j'adore là ça me fait
plaisir de voir ça c'est magnifique
quand c'est beau c'est beau Picot qui
qui veut continuer qui veut dire un mot
c'est vous qui veut dire quoi alors toi
c'est pour qui c'est bon Gilles tu es
une très belle personne tu es mon ami je
t'aime et si un jour je dois faire un
truc avec un homme ce sera avec toi
parce que je trouve que tu as un bon
petit boule en pain d'épice
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
fais gaffe qu'on ne prenne pas pour un
domino
[Rires]
j'ai été Amsterdam même les vendeuses de
tulipes elles sont pas habillées comme
ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous allez voir vous allez voir que
là
qu'il arrête de te sucer déjà
[Applaudissements]
pour sucer il faut parler dans
l'émission donc vas-y
la qualité à la quantité
[Musique]
choisi de dire quelque chose que je
pense à Géraldine
c'est bon c'est annulé vraiment vraiment
je trouve que depuis l'année dernière et
même cette année je trouve que il prend
des risques parfois dans ses démissions
et tout seul contre tous il tire il
tient ses propos et j'aime bien ça juste
faire le trajet pour venir c'est pas
prendre ça
que personne ose dire et j'aime bien
Guillaume et je voulais Mathieu Mathieu
Mathieu remonte-nous cette séquence là
parce que donc j'aime pas vraiment
inutile ah vas-y tu es gentil je
reprends pardon ça sortait tout envie de
dire une gentillesse
d'entrer tout de suite Géraldine
la beauté intérieure est égale à la
beauté extérieure c'est une fille qui a
du courage c'est la seule même autour de
la table qui parfois autant parler à toi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
toi
alors oui qu'est-ce que je te disais
Jean-Pierre
voilà c'est toujours droit dans tes
bottes quelques sur l'opinion même si
c'est pas celui du patron qui est en
train de s'étouffer donc bravo tout est
beau et il paraît qu'un certain âge on
ressent à ce qu'on est pourquoi tu es si
belle et voilà pourquoi
j'ai une douleur
je savais pas je sais pas voilà bon
merci